foreign
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we got malabama here
hi everybody TK Coleman Have a Holly
Jolly Christmas we got the rest of our
team here in the studio as well coming
up today on this free public minimal
episode we're speaking with Dr Nicole
lepera and we're talking to a listener
about dealing with guilt we also have an
outstanding lightning round segment a
live stream question and a listener tip
for you you can check out the full three
hour maximal edition of episode 370
where we answer four times the questions
and we dive deep into several simple
living segments that private podcast
episode is out right now at patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free because say with me
y'all
advertisements suck
all right Joe let's start with our
callers if you have a question or
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Colleen hi my
name is Colleen I'm a patreon subscriber
from Mechanicsburg Pennsylvania for a
little bit of background I was diagnosed
with severe degenerative disc disease
early in my 20s and according to my
doctor I have the back of an 87 year old
so this is kind of a little frame of why
I'm asking the questions that I am so
the first being how can I release the
guilt that I feel when others like
specifically my husband want to help me
and and really end up pulling a bit more
of the way because I can't do certain
things
like bending and and that sort of thing
are very difficult for me
and the second being I I worry that in
some ways I'm not the involved parent
because I can't run around with my
daughter or I can't run around with the
baby that is on the way here in November
and I struggle with that um I don't want
them to remember that when they get
older that Mom couldn't run around
so I just really am looking for some
ways to poke holes in both of these
feelings that I'm having as part of my
chronic pain that I deal with daily
wow Colleen there's a whole lot of
weight here and joining us in the studio
to help us answer this question is
former podcast guest and one of our
favorite people in the world Dr Nicole
lepera is here yes
so Dr Le Pere you've got a new book out
we're going to be talking about it and I
think this is the perfect opportunity to
all hold it up here if you're watching
the video version of the podcast how to
meet yourself it's so I love this
because it's a workbook yeah and
whenever I usually think about workbooks
I'm like oh I feel like my daughter
whenever I'm forced to like I hand
homework over to her and she's like oh
no I think about but then I I crack this
open I'm like oh no this is welcoming
this is completely different and we're
talking to Colleen here about guilt the
guilt that she's experiencing from well
the the what she's setting up for other
people in her life she's setting up sort
of these expectations that she thinks
other people might have of her and
therefore she knows she can't meet those
expectations and it is causing a lot of
additional pain in her life she's
already experiencing pain she has a back
of an 87 year old which I can certainly
relate to that and
um I broke my back when I was young I
thought all kinds of back problems and I
it's limited me in a way right but I
found that freedom is sometimes found in
the acceptance of our limitations can
you talk about these uh things in in the
new workbook but what insights do you
have for Colleen absolutely well first
and foremost thank you all for having me
back on again uh Gil is definitely
something that I know very much through
my own personal journey I call it the
feel bads I've been plagued with them
for as long as I can remember and to
speak to your very wise Point Joshua
oftentimes when we set up an expectation
or we imagine and others have
expectations of us often in our
relationships is when we end up feeling
badly or feeling guilty and to speak to
your point in terms of acceptance and
even feeling really near and dear
calling to your question having had
myself a mother who was riddled with
chronic pain and very much largely
unable to be physically active with me I
really want to differentiate again going
back to expectations and it sounds like
there's a lot of expectation around your
physical abilities and of course that's
a very difficult thing I think is our
body declines at whatever age that is to
throw away that expectation to sit in
the acceptance of the much more limited
you know Mobility that we might have but
I also want to offer how important
presence in and of itself is outside of
you know doing things with our children
our loved ones or whomever that might be
performing in a very real active way in
our relationships as far as I say it
being present to our children and
thinking back and when I'm sharing about
my own mom Not only was she physically
not present for me emotionally and
intentionally she also wasn't present
and that attentional neglect or that you
know disconnection that I suffered
actually carried more of damage and
wounding for myself than her lack of
physical presence so in terms of you
know guilt really unpacking first and
foremost what are the expectations that
we have on ourselves outside of what we
think other people are wanting us to do
a lot of times we we suffer or create
our own suffering because we have an
idea of what it should or shouldn't be
and learning to accept our physical
limitations but also to explore other
ways to be fully present with our
children will probably be the gift that
they are looking to have Beyond you
being physically able and capable it
seems to me that we show up and notice
the ways in which we're unable to show
up as opposed to looking at how we can't
look I can't show up physically in this
and environment because of some
limitation I have but here are the seven
other ways that I actually can be there
I can be there in terms of my attention
my emotional well-being my stability my
support for this person Ryan this
morning you came barreling into the
studio as he usually does yes there's a
cloud whatever I was five minutes early
I left my house way too soon no I came
oh go ahead you guys so you came in you
said you were talking about the guilt
that you had been feeling and I wanted
you to reveal that story to Nicole here
because I thought she might have some
nice insights on it yeah so I love what
you're saying about being present and
when I am giving myself torment with
guilt it is completely taken me out of
the moment so
my problem with guilt is I go out of my
way to like
think about all my past mistakes the
past things that I've done where I've
wronged people uh you know bad decisions
I've made and I like Fester this guilt
that I've already went through by the
way so when I feel guilty not only does
it take me out of the moment but it's
also repeating the process that I
already went through so the other night
what I was excited about is I had this
like huge Revelation with my own guilt
so I'm laying in bed I can't sleep and
that's for some reason uh mostly when
all the guilt comes up and I'm certainly
like beating myself up over some things
and I'm like why am I doing this to
myself and I'm like well Ryan you must
like feeling guilty and I'm like no
that's stupid why would I like feeling
guilty and then I'm like well you
consistently beat yourself up with it
you must feel like you're getting
something out of it and then it hit me
to me my guilt is sanctimonious
I was programmed as a kid from a child
uh as being raised um as one of
Jehovah's Witnesses which is just a very
Christian religion fundamentalist
fundamentalist and I was taught that
feeling guilty
was a good thing virtuous yeah exactly
exactly so
um as soon as I as soon as I had that
Revelation where I'm like oh like this
it's not that I like feeling guilty as
much as I like feeling virtuous and the
more guilty I feel the more virtuous I
must be but as soon as I had that
Revelation I was like oh like I don't
have to beat myself up and it was so
much easier to like even in that moment
it was easy to let go of a lot of that
guilt so you know when I think about
um Colleen's question here it's not
about
um you know uh trying to look at every
single thing that you can't do it's yeah
it's okay to feel guilty don't stew in
that guilt because it's taking you out
of the moment and then there are other
things you can do that
um you know where you can add value to
other people's lives or instead she's
kind of beating herself up feeling like
she is maybe taking value but that's
kind of where I'm at with it now it's
like okay like if I feel guilty about
something like a
um I need to stop doing things that make
me feel guilty step number one and then
uh yeah step number two is like go out
of my way to be the person that I want
to be and and show up how I'm able to
show up and uh yeah it's like just I
mean just like three days of this like I
have not beat myself up not nearly as
much as what I used to
yeah
you're saying something really wise in
terms of the energy and attentional
expenditure that happens when we are
ruminating on anything a guilt-inducing
past event or whatever it might be an
upsetting you know when we're oftentimes
carrying our own suffering when we're
thinking about it and to speak to your
point it often does happen when we don't
have that external focus of the day's
events and the endless distractions that
many of us have so at night in the
mornings when our attention isn't
elsewhere we can really spin in our mind
and to speak to your point it really is
energy expenditure it's attentional
expenditure it's removing the focus from
being not only present but being able to
actualize our true thoughts and feelings
and this really maps onto the book in
terms of when you say sanctimonious a
lot of times when we're feeling guilty
we're feeling guilty about an actual
inner desire an instinct maybe an actual
aspect of our authentic self and yet
usually based on past experiences
conditioned reasons areas circumstances
environments where it wasn't safe or
where we weren't you know we didn't have
the Curious parent to allow us to
express ourselves we then limit and
we're perception then managing in a way
we have an idea of what's moral of what
sanctimonious what's good right bad or
whatever it is person and then we use
that as our touch point and what we're
really though doing is oftentimes
suppressing actual aspects of our
desires our inner wants our longings and
ultimately things that make us us yeah
yeah
you know there's this episode of fresh
off the boat where uh the one of the
lead characters picks up his cousin at
the airport and he reaches for his
luggage and says I got it and then his
cousin says no no I'll carry it and he
goes no I'll carry it and the two of
them start wrestling in the airport over
who's going to carry the luggage they
get to the door one cousin runs through
the door to be first to open it for the
other and the other races him and they
trip over each other to be the guy who
gets to open the door for the other guy
and the amusing thing about it is that
both of these guys had this highly
developed capacity to be generous but
only if they were the ones who got to be
generous and love isn't measured just by
our capacity to give but also by our
capacity to allow others to have the
opportunity to give it's like with
compliments right so much easier to give
one but as soon as you try to give me
one I'm going to start putting up all
sorts of defenses and explaining it away
my brother took me out one time and he
reached for the check to pay for it and
I says no no man I got it and he says
don't do that I got it and I go no no I
got it and he says look man
I love doing things for people there's a
special joy that I get out of it when
you refuse to let me pay for the meal
you're actually taking away an
opportunity for me to do something for
you which is what gives me joy and it's
the first time that I felt guilty in
Reverse guilty not for let not for
letting someone else do something for me
but for refusing to let someone else do
for me and you know one of the things I
would just say here is that the people
in your life they love you and I would
encourage you to not reduce their love
to a transaction that says if you do
something for me that means I am
obligated to do something of equal
capacity for you but rather to allow
them to love you to allow them to help
you and say this is a part of what love
is you are giving me something that I
can't give back to you and that's what
makes the relationship healthy yeah
that's that's really really beautiful TK
and there's so much that I see in my own
past in terms of driving to perform in a
very similar way in my relationships
always trying to you know be the do-good
or grab that check be the supportive
friend and I really had to explore for
myself how difficult it it has and
continues to be for me to be on that
receiving end especially for me around
emotional support thinking back to that
Mom who was very emotionally unavailable
I have had you know a very habitual
pattern of not having someone show up to
meet my emotional needs so I have a very
deep rooted you know feeling of
unworthiness to even ask and I have
beautiful partners that live with me and
are endlessly available to support me
and there's so many moments where it's
so hard for me to gesture to directly
say I need support and actually I do
quite the opposite sometimes I put my
daggers out I say you know why aren't
you helping and supporting me and in
reality I've had to explore my
participation in that pattern which is
it's deeply uncomfortable to beat
someone one who is in need and is in of
state of vulnerability so going back to
Colleen really exploring how it is for
you to be on that receiving end and
possibly you know uncovering that deep
discomfort because as logical as it is
it's very hard for a lot of us to
receive yeah I want to say one quick
thing about this receiving compliments I
just realized like I have this story I
tell myself or like I'm not good enough
I'm not you know I'm not the man I want
to be like and I you know repeat this
narrative a lot and when someone gives
me a compliment it makes that narrative
not true
and there's something about that that's
why it's hard for me to receive
compliments it's because I'm telling
myself this story and when you give me a
compliment I'm like well that can't be
true because this is my this is my story
clearly you don't know you don't know
who I am it's
incongruous with the narrative you've
created about yourself right and right
I've realized that I don't like the way
you treat my best friend thanks man
thanks for sticking up for me I'm okay
I'm gonna have to ask you to stop okay
uh Colleen I'd love to see a copy of the
book how to meet your self uh before we
wrap up her question though Nicole I
wanted to talk to you about last couple
times we've had you on the podcast it
was uh your first book how to do the
work this is actually doing the work
though ironically right because it's a
workbook of sorts what was the impetus
of writing the book
um writing how to do the work as
practical as you know I attempted to
make it at the end of every chapter
there's Journal prompts and you know
tools to use I was very clear as I was
writing it there was so much more of the
journey and My Hope was to offer people
a road map regardless of where they are
on their Journey just starting off well
into it to be able to have that that
reference point and also honoring the
fact that you know our Journeys look
different we take different amounts of
time at different stages so really
giving people that home base to kind of
come back to check in on and you know
kind of referencing also I think the
first question I got after how to do the
work was wow there's so much to be
conscious of how do I even begin to
explore all this nature of my being so
that became the natural Next Step was to
ride the workbook of that exact journey
and that road map so good Ryan what time
is it you know what time it is it's time
for the lightning round where we answer
your questions from Tick Tock yes indeed
you can follow the Mentalist on Tick
Tock Instagram Facebook and Twitter at
the minimalists during the lightning
rounds where we each have 60 seconds on
the clock to answer your questions with
a short share terrible less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share or pithy
answers on social media if you'd like
you can find those show notes at the
minimalists.com podcast or we deliver
them straight to your inbox every Monday
for free whenever send you spam or junk
or advertisements but if you're on our
email list we'll send you our minimal
maxims each week our podcast show notes
and every Thursday we also have the
simple newsletter malabama looks like
Hannah from Tick Tock has a question for
us I go by the Fred Rogers idea of look
for the helpers but you warned that
helpers could enable more problems where
does the desire to help come from and
how do we know when to act on it so
Danny unknown for some context real
quick before we start the clock Danny
unknown he put up a tick tock on our
Tick Tock account which social just then
you know she shared right which by the
way she's out right now on maternity
leave congratulations to yeah social
justice I'm so excited for her and her
husband yeah they uh they have their
first kid now and um it was so late that
they named it TK Coleman
it's funny because TK is always late
and reason Ryan wanted to bring you on
board that's right someone who's later
so that's all wrong
I feel like I beat riot here so many
times
I'm like Dennis Robin it's like my
reputation is so bad that it's gonna
take at least three years of being the
first guy here to even remotely Josh
gets here like 6 a.m so uh good luck
well the Dennis Rodman thing is mainly
because you walked in here with a nose
ring and a wedding dress and you you had
a leopard spotted hair yeah
come on though Dennis Rodman that is so
badass though man oh yeah yeah he's so
punk rock dude anyway we put this video
up on Tick Tock and it basically said
hey the helper is one of the most
dangerous people in the world because he
will tear an eagle out of the sky to
keep him from falling or tear a fish out
of the sea to keep him from drowning you
know this is so the helper is an actual
Enneagram personality
and um this would be like the unhealthy
version of the helper and so when I love
the things exactly and so go ahead and
put 60 seconds on the clock for me
Professor Sean I'll give you something
pithy and we'll unpack this together
to support someone is to accept them for
who they are without trying to change
them manipulate them or persuade them
that's what I'm talking about when I'm
talking about support when I'm talking
about help I'm talking about someone who
forces someone to change manipulates
them moves them in my direction
convinces them coerces them to my point
of view and that's when helping someone
becomes unhealthy if you want to help
someone in the Fred Rogers sense because
you want to provide support for them
when they need support oh I really need
to lean against you TK TK has allowed me
to lean against him Ryan has certainly
allowed me to lean against him it has
helped me but he wasn't looking to help
me in those scenarios he was looking to
be that support structure so that I
could be the best version of me yeah all
right give me 60 seconds
about the flow
[Laughter]
oh man uh my pithy answer is this you
can't help someone who doesn't desire
help and I think this is where the big
problem is with with uh people who go
out of their way to just help other
people now the look for the helpers that
whole philosophy I love that because you
know during times of distress we want to
look for the people who are there to
support who are there to
um you know help wherever the help is
desired and needed but the problem is
what Josh just said when we try to help
someone who doesn't want help like
that's that's where um a we're not doing
that person any service and uh we're
definitely doing ourselves a disservice
so I remember
um someone asked me to sit down with
someone else I'm trying to like be as
ambiguous as possible and they were like
this person really needs your help and
so I was like 27 28 years old and I said
all right I'm gonna help him and I sat
down in stone cold face and I realized
like oh this person doesn't want to be
helped and that is where I learned that
lesson Ryan it's um
the thing about the helper the spirit of
the Fred Rogers
Maxim here look for the helpers what
he's really saying here is look for the
supporters the people who are willing to
support you when you are asking for that
help when I'm talking about the danger
of the helper I'm talking about the
person who goes around and tries to
change everyone because they end up
shooting all over everyone else we were
talking about this on the the private
podcast earlier
about when you start to identify the
universal shoulds for other people yeah
let me tell you what's wrong with you
yes let me tell you what you should be
doing let me let me tell you what you
need right let me drag you to success
Kicking and Screaming well that's not
success it's failure and so if I am
forcing help upon you then no one has
helped I feel bad because you didn't
make the change and then you feel bad
because I was manipulating you changing
you and also now you feel like you
should do the thing that I wanted you to
do let's throw 60 seconds on the clock
for TK Coleman yeah if you're trying to
be a hero for someone that would rather
save themselves then you're really just
a villain in Disguise you're a villain
with a cool Halloween costume
you're most helpful when you respect
other people's intention to evolve if
someone is saying hey no please don't
save me I've got it I'm okay even if I'm
struggling a little bit I want to work
through this process on my own and do it
without you and you insist no I'm gonna
help you then that's really not for them
that's just for their ego and as I heard
it said before of all crimes the
greatest treason is to do the right
thing for the wrong reason and that's
the wrong reason to help anybody I'm
helping them so that I can feel useful
independently of my actual usefulness to
them based on their priorities based on
their preferences based on their stated
needs let's check in with our patreon
live stream here in a moment but first
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists
I wrote down 12 years of minimalist I
think we need to do an episode called
that because this week Ryan Nicodemus
you and I
we ponied up seven dollars and we bought
this little domain called the
minimalists.com I still owe you 350.
it thanks for reminding me
Ryan's close to being debt free and so
if you look December 14 2010 and you've
got a hyphen actually technically be an
in-dash but we'll get into that in some
other how to write better podcast
episode
and then you have now which is December
2022 we have 12 years and the thing that
I realized just yesterday Ryan is that
we have now been doing the minimalism
thing for longer than we did the
corporate world thing while this week is
so wild I was 12 years in the corporate
world climb the corporate ladder
achieved all of the success so we're at
this it's equidistant for us right now
we're at this middle point where it's 24
years of corporate on one side
minimalism on the other side and there's
a whole lot that's represented by that
little hyphen between 2010 and 2022.
we've done so much over the course of
these 12 years I never anticipated us
making a documentary let alone two or
the Emmy nominations or the books or
starting this podcast yeah being a New
York Times bestseller fields and
and what I what I've realized is that
all of the moments that really mattered
in between 2010 and now it has something
to do not with achievement like a New
York Times thing or Emmy nomination or
whatever else it has to do with the
people who we've helped heal and that
healing
started with ourselves and that's what
Dr Nicole's book is really about it's
about self-healing in a way and this
journey allowed us to heal ourselves and
share
how we have healed and that enabled a
lot of healing in other people a lot of
self-healing for them as well speaking
of on a personal note uh this week I'm
going overseas for a stem cell treatment
and so I'll be gone for a week I've had
this terrible autoimmune disease for the
last four years and so while I'm gone
Bex and I are gonna fly overseas I'm
gonna do this week-long stem cell thing
hoping that it improves my my autoimmune
condition and in the process I'm going
to be listening to my favorite albums
from 2022 so every year for the last I
guess 12 years now I've put out a list
of my favorite albums of the Year sorry
TK once again no Christmas album has
made this list Bieber have a 20-22 album
no I don't think so but uh there's a
whole list if you are on our email list
that'll come out to you this week you
can also find it at the minimalist.com
sound as in the sound of Life music's
been a very important part of my journey
and us being the minimalists we're
always bringing musicians on the road
with us when we do tour stops we've been
doing the Sunday symposiums with live
music and live music or just music in
general creates a soundtrack for our
lives so if you want to find some of my
favorite music from the last 12 months
the minimalists.com slash sound or sign
up for our email list it'll show up
right there in your inbox and you can
also let me know send me a tweet or a
message on any of the social media
platforms let me know what your favorite
album of the year was let's check in
with our patreon live stream real quick
from Alabama you got a question for us I
sure do here's a question from
minimalist gecko I spend nearly half of
my income and ton of time traveling to
my job but my partner insists that the
stability and benefits make it
worthwhile how do I explain to them the
misery it's causing me doesn't make it
worth it to me it's worth your misery TK
I love that you get to decide isn't that
the best when other people tell folks
what's worth their time yeah oh man but
I get the complexity
when it's a spouse right yeah but when
it's a significant other it it feels
like the rules ought to be different
right I mean how do you tell your
significant other the same way you told
us you tell them truthfully you tell
them eye to eye you tell them face to
face you tell them with transparency and
and and conviction and and you you tell
them with all the filling that is there
right I I know that you say it's
worthwhile for me to do this and I
understand why it's worthwhile to you
and I still want to fight for what's
worthwhile to you but I need to fight in
a way that doesn't erode my soul I need
to fight in a way that doesn't make me
dead inside I need to fight in a way
that allows me to still show up and be a
self that actually has the capacity to
enjoy the benefits of my work and I'm
losing me
in the Quest for this thing that is
supposed to be worthwhile at the expense
of my own soul I never knew what selling
my soul looked like but now I'm starting
to get a glimpse of what that might be
for me I think you gotta just say it
like it is you know say it like it is
and then say is there a way we can fight
together for what's worthwhile without
it being something that makes me feel
like
my life is hell is it Demello the uh I
could prove to you that you don't want
to be happy yes yeah and uh it's so
it's just so true uh so what does he say
Josh he says so he's got this book
called awareness and he says you don't
want to be happy the the first step in
becoming happy is realizing that you
don't want to become happy right now
what does that mean you don't want to be
happy yes yes I do oh no you don't I can
prove it to you I want you to go to the
person who's close to you or one of the
people closest to you and say I would
rather have happiness than have you
um
yeah imagine how difficult it is to say
that yeah and it's difficult to say that
because we think well there's a lot of
hubris caught up in this as well
I need to be your source of happiness
and I need you to be my source of
happiness but what happens here in those
cases is that is now conditional love
which is not love at all love with
conditions is like or in this case it is
misery it creates a particular kind of
misery I need you to need me and I need
you and therefore we're both unhappy but
at least we're unhappy together yeah
yeah and so from that perspective
there's just something about
um
realizing that okay we're not happiness
is not the ultimate goal but you know to
get practical with this question it's
really what your partner wants is
stability and security
so that if you want to get your partner
on board you have to show them that
you're still able to provide that
security and stability it might be in a
different way maybe it's a little less
money but the amount of money doesn't
really matter as long as your partner
still feels that sense of security so
that's that's what I would you know
challenge this person to think a
minimalist gecko to think like how can
you show your partner that you're still
going to provide what what they need
yeah or the desire by the way I spent a
lot of a lot of time in my life being
kind of like a pushover
um where I would be truly angry at
people and truly upset with the way they
were treating me and and I just couldn't
understand why they wouldn't respect my
consistent pleas you know somebody maybe
would push me a certain way and I'd be
like come on man chill stop and they do
it again come on man stop you know chill
chill out man and they do it again and I
just couldn't understand it like I'm
verbalizing that I don't like this I'm
literally saying come on man chill you
know I'm I I'm honestly showing how I
want to be bothered and I would I would
resent people because I would feel like
you're you're making me evil like you
need me to be the kind of person who's
gonna punch you in the face in order for
you to get the point that I don't like
what you're doing and so then I started
to get really upset at people and and
that's never helpful that's really
helpful especially with gekko's question
here bringing that emotion into this hey
you are making me miserable
um that is a way to escalate and then
the other person becomes defensive then
you become defensive or you become
offensive and they become offensive and
you're creating world war three in your
household as opposed to simply saying
hey this is making me miserable can we
work together so you can help me find an
off-ramp for my own misery that's right
that's right and and what I learned from
that is people don't respond to how you
feel on the inside and they don't always
respond to uh your verbalization of
emotion but what they respond to is the
commitment you have to establishing a
boundary and still being able to love
them from within in that boundary so
what changed for me is when I started
telling people hey look when I say chill
I really mean it I need that to stop I
need that to be the last time that it
ever happens now we can be cool we can
still be homies but if that's the
boundary that can't be respected we
can't be cool we can't be homies but I
really need that to stop right and I
think in this case you don't have to say
look you can you can you can uh take the
highway or my way but I think there is
space to say Hey look
I truly can't do this anymore I'm no
longer physically and psychologically
available for this particular thing I
thought I could but I was wrong however
I am totally committed to figuring out
what's best for us I'm totally committed
to getting the things that we agreed
that we're going to get or having a
conversation about what a viable
alternative would be but I can't go
about it this way I think that's fair
we have several more questions from the
live stream we'll check in with those
later on the private podcast but before
we get to our listener tip today coming
up on the maximal episode this week
we've got a million more questions for
Dr Nicole lapera you can uh check her
out over there she answered a bunch of
questions with us we also some more
questions from social media and the live
stream we've got a private minimalist
home tour Nicodemus will be joining us
for that one we have our ambassad or
trash it segment TK's tweet of the week
we have an outstanding added value
segment it's my favorite piece of
clothing I'll just leave it at that
added value my favorite piece of
clothing and we've got much much more of
less and if you want to hear all that
check out the minimalist private podcast
at patreon.com
the minimalist Alabama what else you got
for us here's a minimalist Insight from
one of our listeners
this is Elizabeth from Houston Minnesota
and like many families we have struggled
with calendar clutter I felt like I was
always telling people we should get
together but then rarely following
through
a few years ago we started Monday fun
day where every Monday in June through
August we host a potluck gathering at
our house we usually run 5 PM to dark
it's a no pressure no obligation event
we set up outside and we get anywhere
from 20 to 40 people every week
we don't make any changes around the
house or do any extra special teams our
guests just get to see us as we are
now when I run into family and friends I
just invite them to Monday fun day I
find we have stronger better connections
with people and less stress about
schedules and obligations
all right y'all that's our minimal
episode for today we'll see you on
patreon for the full three hour maximal
edition of episode 370 Dr Nicole apparel
will be there with us to answer a bunch
more of your questions by the way shout
out to Dr lepera you can check out her
new book it's called how to meet
yourself you can also follow her and
millions of other people do this follow
her on social media we'll put links to
her social media in the show notes she's
known as the holistic psychologist over
there and you can check out her podcast
I'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well you can find all of those
show notes at the minimalists.com
podcast if you leave here today with
just one message
please let it be this
month people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign